Oftentimes, it is possible to find other
relevant information to add to the dataset.
In sales forecast, it's often not
sufficient to use internal data.
It is common to collect comparison
information and macroeconomic information.
At other times, a dataset may contain duplicate
information or columns that are not informative.
As an example, sales amount is often kept
in multiple currency in IT system. However,
only sales amount in one currency should
be used in analysis, otherwise can cause
numeric difficulties in analysis. Additional
variables can come from several sources.
First, datasets are often compiled from
online and public data sources. It is
often possible to collect additional
information from those sources.
Second, it is also possible and sometimes
necessary to create additional variables
from the data, including dummy variables
and transformed variables, and interactions.
It is common to create dummy variables from
a single variable that takes a small number
of fixed values. Each of the values is called a
category and the variable is called a categorical
variable. We can create m minus 1 dummy variables,
from a categorical variable with m categories,
where m is an integer. Each dummy
variable takes the value of 0 or 1,
where 1 usually indicates
yes and a 0 indicates no.
Let's look at an example, the table on the left
shows three property types, single family home,
townhouse and condo. So, there are three
categories and m equal to 3. We can create two
dummy variables D1 and D2, where D1 indicates
whether it is a single family home and D2
indicates whether it is a townhouse. Both D1 and
D2 taking the value 0 indicates a condo, which is
neither a single family house or a townhouse. This
procedure of creating dummy variables can lead
to a large number of dummy variables when there
are many categories for a categorical variable,
which can be problematic when observations for
some categories are sparse. We can systematically
reduce the number of categories by combining
categories that are close to each other.
Going back to the same example in a original
dataset, there are many categories other than
single family home, townhouse and the condo.
Depending on the purpose of our analysis we may
choose to combine some categories. For example,
condo, coop, multi-family and mobile home can
all be mounted to the others category. In this
way, we end up using only two dummy variables,
instead of five should we not combine categories.
However, be caution that, how categories should
be combined is not always straightforward and
it should be chosen carefully. It is common
to combine sparse categories together, but
it may also depend on the problem context.
As we discussed before, we may want
to remove variables from our data set.
The first motivation is to simplify model and
analysis. Some variables may not contain much
useful information and therefore do not deserve
added complexity for including them in analysis.
There are also cases when some variables
contain the same information, and we should
only keep one of them. By removing variables
and including a smaller set of variables,
we end up with more parsimonious models,
which also tend to be easier to interpret.
Note that some methods do not work well
when the distribution for a variable
is degenerate, meaning that the
variable only takes a single value.
Variables with degenerate distributions
have to be removed for better performance.
A variable with degenerative distribution is also
called a zero variance variable in exploratory
data analysis. For example, if everybody in a
high school class are born in the same year,
then the first year is a zero variance variable,
and is not a relevant variable in analysis,
including it may cause numeric difficulties. It is
more common to have near-zero variance variables
where only a very small portion of the data
takes a different value. If all students in
the class are born in the same year except one
student, then the first year is a variable with
near-zero variance. Keeping zero variable
or near-zero variance variables can cause
cardinality issues in regression analysis, where
coefficient estimates can change erratically,
when there are small changes to the data,
such behavior is clearly undesirable.